Martin Scorsese did a film a documentary
I don't know if how what widely
distributed it is but it's called my
voyage to Italy the film is a reference
I believe to one of the greatest films
ever made in the Italian tradition
voyage to Italy by Roberto Rossellini
Rossellini's film voyage to Italy is
about a couple that's really teetering
their marriage is on the brink of a
divorce Ingrid Bergman and George
Sanders traveled by car from London to
Naples to claim an inheritance left them
by their uncle Homer and it becomes this
kind of eerie cultural descent for this
cult that for this couple into a world
that is alien to them and yet at the
same time reveals the gaping holes in
their emotional connection to me it
always represents the ultimate
confrontation between Italy and the
tourists gaze you know Italy has been
part of the Grand Tour for centuries
right and in the 18th century in the
nineteenth century upper-class patrician
noble people from Europe would travel it
would like you know I joke with my
students I say it was their junior year
abroad they would go to Italy and spend
months sometimes years seeing art
firsthand
you know learning the language seeing
these things that they had spent their
youth studying up close and personal and
oftentimes experimenting with their
identities you know the away from to
leave their home countries and and grow
emotionally before going back to real
life Goethe for example the great German
writer spent a couple years in Italy and
he said it was his rebirth he says when
he arrived in Rome it was really like
you know the day he was born again and
the birth of his aesthetic his
neoclassical aesthetic is is steeped in
this encounter with Rome I think Martin
Scorsese's a similar figure this film my
voice to Italy is an extraordinary
documentary by Scorsese of his take on
Italian film history and he takes you
through Fellini Antonioni Visconti
Rosellini
and he gives a really impressive sense
of the arc of Italian film
and how these not only does he interpret
them he should place key scenes in them
and you get the feeling that he could
not have become a filmmaker without the
experience of Italian film neo-realism
is not just something to be celebrated
but it's also a kind of burden for some
of these young directors because they
feel they can't go past their masters
right as a Fellini once said just
because you see a Shack right and and
some poor people and film them doesn't
mean it's neo-realism right but it had
that that movement had such a kind of
pole on on film history not just in
Italy but throughout the world and that
Scorsese documentary is really a
testament to someone who's not you know
who's it's also you know he's an
italian-american he feels a special
connection to it but how a film
tradition that's not in the country he's
lived most of his life in could still
kind of be his like a film school in